so uh hi everyone welcome to NDC Sydney
it's so good I am a little bit excited
that we're actually doing this in person
for a change
um has anyone been to a in-person
conference since pre I don't know the
Dark Ages before covert
yep okay good
um
so I think this is a great chance for us
all to connect and meet each other
hopefully when you're in between
sessions you do the the nerdy introvert
thing of making sure you don't talk to
anyone you just kind of stand near other
people and
you know look like that
um that said feel free to come up and
talk to me anytime at all I'm quite
happy to have a chat to anyone
um if there's questions coming out from
this talk as well or or you're
interested in a job with Willow sorry
um add you know got to do that sort of
thing
um I am happy to talk my name is Richard
Banks you can see it on the screen there
I'm not going to talk about myself other
than to say I am a distinguished
engineer at Willow and distinguish just
means old apparently so that's why the
gray hair or the lack of
um and I was one of those people who put
their hands up for more than 20 years
doing something I was like you can't
tell right I look like I'm 18. it's
great
um
so um when we're talking this is a talk
about performance by the way um before I
move on to the the next slide
um you probably figured that out from
the name
hopefully hopefully
um but the the intent of this talk was
is really driven by what we've seen in
the net space over the last
three four releases now five you know
from basically full framework to dot net
core two was kind of like let's make it
work and then at three Microsoft went
let's make this thing bloody fast
and then they made it faster and then
they you know skipped four and went to
five
um and that got faster again and then
six has become faster again and with
seven there's even more work and I don't
know if any of you have had a look at uh
some of the posts coming out of
Microsoft recently around the
performance improvements that happen
within the framework itself and the low
level detail they go to to explain
how they've optimized code that is in
hot paths so that that everyone using
the framework gets lifted up by those
changes
uh and you look at it and you go through
the details it's like
bloody hell how do I do this this is
kind of propeller head stuff what I want
to do is take the the idea and the
process of performance Improvement and
figure out how we can apply it to our
own code
so that performance improvements is
something that we can all adopt and all
benefit from and that it's not
the inner workings of a.net framework
that give us performance but it's just
going through the steps of what's there
so this is effectively going to be a
walkthrough of a library which I will
give you the name of in a little bit
explaining how the process works what we
want to be thinking about and going from
there now the obvious tip for any type
of performance improvements the primary
goal is very simple
I know genius
that's why I'm standing up the front and
you're not
um do less and that's a great tip and at
that point we could just stop the talk
here and we're done because we've done
less
um
in reality is less water right so less
IO is the obvious thing for most of our
applications we're not doing Frameworks
we're not doing a lot of CPU stuff most
of our applications are going to be
doing less i o
the classic n plus one calls to
databases is anyone other than me done
that
or you're just liars
okay all right the second one got it
um less IO is really important even just
the amount of things you might make the
same number of calls but if you reduce
your bandwidth you will get better
performance because you're sending less
data less i o to disk you know all these
sort of operations any CPU improvements
and performance improvements at a CPU
level are going to be dwarfed by the
improvements that you can make in terms
of i o I don't know if you've seen this
at all I ran across this years ago it's
the idea of if if we take IO or compute
latency and expand that to human scale
what happens
so if we consider one CPU cycle is you
know one human second
I like some of the numbers here for
example
memory access is about four minutes I
can save something to
to memory in or do a memory operation in
four minutes so I'll get back to you
we'll just sit around and wait
it's not very exciting or we get right
down the bottom the
using the internet send a message
between San Francisco and New York
five years
now the obvious thing is if that was
real then uh what did you do at work
today dear
um
I'm still sending that packet
I'll get back to you in five years time
the boss is going to be like good job
good job well done you get a raise
um but of course we're in Australia our
internet is so much better than that
right
Sydney to New York anyone want to guess
30 years maybe something like that at
human scale
so what did you do in your career
I sent a message to New York all the
best
um and if we think about that you can
see you know the the performance
improvements from an i o perspective
versus CPU and everything else it's just
chalk and cheese
so always focus on performance around i
o first so that's why I have it top and
there's why it's the red line item there
beyond that we have thread blocking
anything that's going to block execution
garbage collector classic example this
is why async and await has become so
popular in recent times because we can
start doing more things while threads
are waiting for Io to complete and the
like so we want to keep on top of that
you can overdo it I had some code I was
looking at a little while ago and I
didn't write it which is unusual where
we basically took a piece of work and
spread it across multiple threads so
many threads that we started the thread
pull
um good job because we didn't think
about maximums and we just made the
whole application worse because then
we've got overheads of thread creation
and we're all sitting around waiting for
a turn no one's getting anything but
it's multi-threaded why is it not
working that's again just my experience
right no one else has done that
okay good yeah yeah all right well I'm
going to learn from you guys
um and the last one being CPU they're
obviously everything at the end of the
day runs with CPU we want to focus on
that as well but it is third in the
hierarchy of what we normally think
about
um
this is where also memory allocation
comes into play memory allocation Drive
CPU load you have to allocate the memory
you have to deallocate it you have to
keep track of it it's all CPU time and
there are other benefits around
improving performance from a CPU
perspective is in such as
heat generation
something we need to consider Green
Computing initiatives heat generation
energy consumption if I use less CPU I'm
using less energy and given where we're
at with energy these days and the
impending energy crisis thanks to
electric cars and everything else that's
going to occur
guaranteed and you should probably jump
to I think Richard Campbell's doing a
talk on this later tomorrow might be
worth going to
um
a lot of that is going to be really
important for us that that
Green Computing initiatives that are
happening will end up impacting our
industry and we will have to pay
attention to it so performance
Improvement is valuable from that
perspective
all right so that's the Preamble the way
I think about performance as you can see
I treat it like detective work I don't
want to say I'm Sherlock Holmes because
I'm not
um but I do like that idea of there is a
problem I'm trying to discover what the
problem is I'm trying to find the root
cause of what's going on and then I'm
going to problem solve that thing so not
only do I find the culprit and go aha
Watson
um but I'm also then going to take that
culprit and beat the crap out of them
um
so to speak I'm not in occurring
violence in the room at all
but to then improve that situation and
make things better so it's kind of cool
I like puzzle solving it's great fun I
like the idea of investigating so I
enjoy this sort of work now there are
some prerequisites before doing that
good test coverage too many times I've
seen people named Richard
um
go and do some performance Improvement
and think everything's wonderful
Go and show someone else how wonderful
the performance is only to realize the
performance is great because I actually
skipped a whole lot of processing that
should have occurred
so test coverage gives you that safety
net um and these days hopefully
I'm not even going to ask hopefully we
have good test coverage in our
applications or at least enough to have
some confidence
and the other thing that that we have as
a prerequisite is our mindset the
biggest thing from a performance work
perspective to have in your mindset is
Thinking Beyond the abstractions it's
really easy with Computing obviously
these days that we have abstraction
after abstraction after abstraction but
all of it all comes down to what's
happening on the network and what's
happening in the CPU effectively or
what's happening in terms of IO and and
being too abstracted is a problem Entity
framework for example is great in that
it lets you
interact with databases without having
to really think about it but we've all
seen
maybe not all of us some of us might be
perfect the rest of us have seen really
bad results from EF code that has been
he is doing the right thing but our
usage of it is bad because we didn't
understand the abstractions
um that said by the way.net 7 coming up
recently uh next month
coming up recently in the future
coming up next month has some good
improvements from performance around EF
itself they've done some work to try and
remove and reduce round tripping to
databases for certain types of
operations which is fantastic because
we're going to get for most of our
applications a great performance
Improvement by doing nothing else other
than updating to the latest version
it's like yes that's my kind of
improvement
so there are things we are then running
a simple Loop which is identify
something that matters
to our end users there's no no point
spending three weeks four weeks doing a
performance Improvement to save 20
milliseconds off an operation that
happens once a year it's not really a
return on investment on that so find
something that matters to your users
that has value Baseline your current
performance
this is obvious hopefully make the
change
assess your performance rinse and repeat
am I going to do exactly that
we're going to do this with a library
called PDF pig that's the name of the
talk see what I did there it's pretty
good
pad on the back for myself PDF pig is a
pretty popular Library uh it's a port of
Apache box uh PDF box as you can see
um I'm using version 0.7 because the
team that writes or looks after
maintains pdfp has done their own
performance improvements so I didn't
want to take something that was already
well optimized and then try and improve
that I wanted to cheat and make it
easier for myself so I've gone back to a
previous version
um
the good things around this and why I'm
using it is it's fairly isolated which
is Handy for a talk
it's a library so it's good and it's got
good test Suite so there's good coverage
on this
um anyone use this by the way I'm
curious
no anyone never heard of it before and
now goes oh I'd like to use that yeah
okay there we go good all right you're
welcome
um
and we're going to be using a few tools
I don't want to go too deep into a lot
of tooling I'm going to keep this really
simple so that it's something we can all
adapt to and use it at our work so
perfume
benchmark.net I'll put these links up
again at the end speed scope and we're
going to look at the net source code
believe it or not because we need to go
beyond the abstractions
all right so we're going to do it let's
go let's go Richard let's jump across to
vs code excellent all right so vs code
is awesome for doing c-sharp development
there's going to be talk on that later
by gentleman over here Mr melgi
um
I don't use the visual studio idea
anymore
it's no point this does everything I
need and I've got you can see pdfp and
the test Library running there so uh wow
this resolution's fantastic by the way
and I could look at the tests and just
to prove that they run I can run some of
those tests and this all do its thing
and go hey look there's tests and it
works and everything's good I won't run
the entire Suite because the integration
tests take about 10 minutes and it's
probably not a very exciting 10 minutes
watching tests run
um
and I've done what most of us will do
first time we go and do any baselining
of performance which is right our own
little test wrapper utility thing has
anyone done this
this code might look familiar we start
the stopwatch
we make some calls and we've stopped the
stopwatch
print the results of the screen
yeah
who did this last week
okay good all right
so we're going to run this code here and
I'm just going to do the
classic.net run config release
not debug don't make the mistake that I
have done far too many times of
forgetting to put it in release mode
debug is going to be slower you haven't
got the code optimizations you're not
measuring what your users will see so
run it in release mode and this is going
to do its thing and cool it took 7.6
seconds to process a PDF file
figure out these 838 pages and 198 320
words
beautiful I'm in fact going to do the
next thing that we all do which is go to
notepad and go cool let me just write
that number down
uh where'd notepad go come back come
back there you are
all right so that is what we say 7.6 7.6
and I'll just zoom that up
7.6 now
what's the problem with what I've just
done problem is my results are highly
inconsistent
because I'm running on an operating
system operating systems are doing other
things at the same time I'm never going
to get a pure result so
liar
Liar Liar
all right we can cheat we can make stuff
happen and we can do this and I'm going
to be now doing things on the operating
system and
come on don't meet me out yes thank you
now it takes longer
so now I might have looked at that first
result and got an 8-0 and then run the
test again and gone seven six and go yes
I've just shaved five percent off my
application
without any real understanding that I've
actually done nothing at all
we have to do performance work by
running out the perf test a lot of times
and looking for deltas and looking at
means and distribution and everything
else we should also make sure that we're
running our machine without background
as few background processes as possible
run it in high performance mode so that
you don't have CPU throttling going on
under the hood again beyond the
abstraction and the like button let's
say for the moment that our number when
we average it out goes to about seven
eight is that okay with people
yeah you're okay okay good all right
first thing Improvement wise that we are
going to do here is I cheated
and I'm running this as a.net31 app
just to show you the improvements in a
framework
let's change that to six
run it again anyone want to guess what
the numbers are going to be
four seconds oh
five seven twelve who said twelve me
6.3 oh okay and we'll run it again and
of course I'll try my best to make it go
slower just for consistency and fun and
you want to see the PDF by the way we're
using homoziliad which has 838 pages
I thought I'd do a small PDF
text Heavy
what's that 6.9 so we're definitely
getting some performance improvements
here which is a good thing
simplest performance Improvement you can
make if you've got old code
update the latest runtime you're going
to get the benefits and when seven comes
out you will get more benefits there is
also a talk later this week uh talking
about the other parts of net performance
and improvements in general profile
guided optimization a whole bunch of
other things that are happening in that
space GC improvements and and the like
if you're interested in this space
strongly recommend going to that one
um I'll be sitting in the back as well a
6.2 6.9 6.3 let's say that's a lazy six
five
for want of a better term so we've just
said 1.3 seconds by doing nothing else
I'm definitely going to the boss and
saying hey can I have a pay rise
they might laugh at me but it doesn't
hurt to try
all right now
that done let's actually
figure out where things are happening
now if I look at my code and I want to
improve this Loop
here I'm opening a document I'm parsing
it getting some structure a number of
pages then there's a loop I don't know
technically I do because I've looked at
it but I don't know looking at the code
where the performance time is where can
I save time in this is it in the parsing
inside PDF document open is it in
hitting some of these methods is it in
get words is it get page I can't tell
some of this could be statically done
when the parsing happens and it's it's a
simple property return it could be much
deeper
I could go and look at the code and try
and Eyeball my way through it again I'm
sure none of us have ever done that
at all
this week
um
I don't want to do that I actually want
to use a tool to do it for me which is
great I'm going to profile the code this
is perfume I can't make the font any
bigger I'm sorry so they're going to be
a little bit of zoomy zoomy going on
it's a technical term Zoomy Zoomy
I'm going to run a command and it's
going to say hey sunshine you're
profiling at the kernel level you need
to elevate
so I will do that
now before I show this UI let me go back
to get out of there and go back to the
slides
this is your typical developer written
user interface
and I'm sure we've never done this
ourselves as well right we like building
the the shuttle control system and
wondering why users don't find it easy
to use
um
there's a few things here first I'm
going to run a command which is our
application our compiled application
it's in release mode obviously
um perfume will take by default a sample
every millisecond so every millisecond
it will stop execution of what's going
on grab the call Stacks of every single
process on the system
so it will slow my machine down
and record that and every millisecond
does the same thing because we want to
see where things are at so sampling
every millisecond we are also going to
capture a few things here we're going to
capture thread time so we can see if
there's threading happening in the
application we're going to look at file
Lao because I know I'm doing some
interaction and I O is important and
we're going to look at memory allocation
to see if we're going to have issues
with garbage collector and and the like
when we've done this
we are also going to see uh some output
that looks a little like this so we will
see a lot of options in terms of what
perfview captures which is great
I don't care about most of them for this
particular case we care about the ones
that are highlighted which are CPU
Stacks garbage collection statistics the
thread time and particularly noting the
ready thread one so this is more where
you've got threads that are available to
do work and ready to do work but can't
so they're blocked and disk IO
reasonable
yes absolutely I think that's great
let's continue he says talking to
himself
all right
put a few turn off thread time I will
just bump this up so it's easier to see
so you can see I'm not lying I turned
off merge because I don't need to share
this file anywhere else well I forgot
that one and run the command the window
disappears and we end up seeing over
here that something's working this is
perfect doing its thing who's used this
tool
okay
um for those who haven't this is a
Microsoft tool
it's very cool
and it's going to spit out some results
and open it up and there we go awesome
so
here's our CPU Stacks our memory and
disk i o and thread time so the first
thing I'm going to look at is the
garbage collector
GC stats
now
I want to go to the performance tester
one and I can see here that it's going
to give me some numbers which is
fantastic
uh let me bump that up just a little
more so it's easier to see here's our
stats of gen 0 1 and 2 Collections and
how long we've paused and what I see
here is that we've made 10
Gen 2 runs and it's cost us in total 8.3
milliseconds
is this our performance bottleneck
cool so from an investigation detective
perspective we can ignore this
yeah we could probably allocate less
memory but it's not our bottleneck so we
need to focus on the things that matter
and it's not that so noting that I go
okay sweet ignore that let's go look at
disk IO
now before I do this
you will see a view that looks something
like this now I'll Zoom it up again
develop your built UI it looks confusing
at the start particularly that thing
above the wind which has the asterisks's
and the letters and the nines and
everything else
perfume has inbuilt help
which is good
it's dense it takes a little bit to read
it and understand at times but it is
like all things with great power comes
terrible documentation
um
but it is really actually pretty good
um because it will tell me what these
dots mean the dot in this case is that
in this in this time period
This Thread process method call whatever
it is on the left consumed
between 0 and 0.1 percent of our total
time or our total metric
and it does 32 buckets across the
execution period that we ran for and
just kind of gives us an ASCII version
of a
a little heat chart thingy
ticker that's the word I'm after which
is nice so when you get used to it you
can eyeball something and go oh okay I'm
not interested that's not my problem
it's in really that that one above
um
which is cool
so let's go back and actually look at
the results that we've got in this
particular case so disk IO stacks
so there is
every process on my system I told you
there's everything so I've
yes you are correct there is a lot of
processes your operating system is doing
in the background and why you get so
much inconsistency in terms of how
things operate
it's kind of frightening
um kind of cool at the same time
so let's open performance tester which
is sorry about the fact that it keeps
moving on me which is this application
here
and looking at this
if I come along
and eyeball
our metric chart here what do I see
this guy oh at the start
probably where we're loading the file up
and not much after that
is this process i o bound
not really
so cool we've eliminated eliminated
another suspect in our investigation D
Watson
so I can move on from that one then I'm
going to go to thread time let's see if
we're blocked on threading
again open the performance tester
cool and I'm just going to go straight
to the name one which looks like the
screenshot I showed earlier
and you'll see now
perfume when you do this particular view
generates
categorizes threads into pseudo States
indicating if it was blocked doing some
CPU work and doing a hard fault
or something else and you can see some
of them here readied by thread ID and
weighting these are the ones we're
interested in
um I'll make that a little bit larger
just because I like zooming in and
making you seasick
um ready by thread ID is basically
saying there's a thread that was readied
by another thing and it was sitting
around and waiting for in this case less
than a millisecond
okay
um
oops almost all right that's horrible
okay coming back up tier block time we
had 88 block time and 11 CPU time are we
in trouble here from a Threading
perspective
it's a trick question everyone's going I
don't know how to answer that one you're
the one up the front
all right turns out not all block time
is created equal
if I go back to the call tree what I see
is I have a startup thread
and then 10 other threads that have been
created by dotnet as part of running the
process and if I come across to the
right I can see time is spent on all
these mostly but
what have we got we got the background
garbage collector we've got the jet
doing its thing the tig compilation
workers stage one and two we've got
the.net finalizer for probably releasing
the file i o file handle that I created
and then a bunch of other threads that
have done a grand total of one
millisecond of time and almost no
processing at all so if I make those
somehow more available
it's not going to help these threads are
blocked because they've got nothing to
do
which is why we want the ready time
that's the one that really counts so
what I see here is if I just
filtered down to my startup thread and
if I right click and include item sorry
about the zooming there I wish I could
control that better
um
and go back to by name I now see CPU
time is 99.2 percent of this application
so
what do we need to investigate
CPU time yay which is exactly the bottom
of the stack that I talked about ironic
I know
um but at least we've done that process
of eliminating candidates and working
through what's important so when IO
gov you know blocking anything okay this
is a CPU bound application now I could
start digging into this in a little more
detail
and I will I'm just going to open the
CPU stacks
for a moment just to have a look at
what's going on here
I can see I have the jit creating arrays
and newing things up and get page doing
something or something along those lines
get page was one of those methods that
we called in our loop it's the one
that's got the most work in here
that's probably our Focus
at this point I can then jump in and try
and dig through everything but I want to
isolate the code a little bit more I
want to isolate the performance I should
mention uh can you see this one here NT
dll question mark exclamation and module
question mark exclamation question mark
this is basically perfume saying I don't
know what symbols you're talking about
you will see uh things like this module
CLR Jets so we've got the module name
before the exclamation point
and then a question mark saying we don't
have the pdbs and the symbols loaded if
you right click one of those rows
do look up symbols
perfume will go and try and load the
symbols from symbol server for the
library and then be able to expand that
into the particular method which is
handy when you want to look at what's
going on inside the framework again
going beyond the abstraction
the module question mark question mark
exclamation question mark exclamation
what the hell
um is effective as saying I can't tell
you what the module name is and I can't
tell you what method in the unknown
module name it is this is typically
caused by Anonymous methods that I
produced or runtime generated code
because they're not statically compiled
at that point as long as that's a small
percentage it's not going to affect your
overall performance if it is you can do
things in perfume to roll those numbers
up into the parent call and basically
look at the parent methods find out
where it's happening
uh we're not going to see a lot of that
so that's more for your information
all right so
I don't want to run this all the time
and try and dig through I'm going to
cheat because I can and I'm going to get
reset so that I can move forward and go
to it's switch step two sorry about that
being on the microphone
and load up benchmark.net who's used
this
again it is a freaking awesome tool
um
it's going to do all the statistical
work that I mentioned before you know
how we were taking eight seconds and I
would have had to run it a few times ago
that's about fingering the air 8.7
seconds to execute
perfume is going to do that for me and
do it much better
um what I need to do is tell perfume
what to Benchmark so I put a benchmark
attribute on a method and run it
which is our get page method that we
looked at earlier I went yeah this is
probably a problem and I'm going to run
it for page number one 20 and 50 to see
if there's any variation between how far
we have to dig through in the PDF file
because maybe each time we ask we're
going back to the start and moving
forward
so let's go run that and we're going to
go dot slash benchmarks and again.net
run release mode
now you will see a few things happening
here firstly there will be three runs of
The Benchmark one for each of the page
numbers that we're getting
benchmark.net will do some nice things
for us firstly it will execute the code
a few times to get the jit to get out of
the way basically ask the jit to do that
initial tiered compilation and and just
say take this method to make sure it's
all sweet
then it will try and run the test a few
times to figure out how many iterations
it can do at once
to get a reasonable number to work with
so in this case we've landed on 512
operations
then it runs those 512 operations a few
times as a batch to see that the numbers
are stable and the guesswork was correct
and then it runs the actual workload and
this actual workload piece where we're
doing the numbers and you can see this
time this is Page 20 because it was the
second one in the list
instead of doing 512 we're doing 128
easy indicator that 20 is going to be
slower than one
and we can see also six milliseconds per
operation these sort of numbers coming
up it's going to do its thing and then
it will pop out and run uh 450 and at
the end once it's all done its magic
we'll be able to compare the results of
time per operation and how much memory
is consumed
um
and if you can Muck around with those
settings in benchmark.net and get other
numbers out of it but it's very very
nice way of doing things so rather than
doing my manual riches crappy
performance tester thing I could have
taken that Loop put it inside
benchmark.net and run it and got a much
more accurate and statistical
representation of the work that was
occurring
it is important by the way to note that
with benchmark.net you need to do
something with the return values
otherwise the compiler is going to go
hey you know what you're not using this
I'm just going to optimize you out when
you're doing release mode and then your
benchmarks are like that's just
fantastic
and again I've never done that and
wondered why my code was so fast
um
so here we go here's our results awesome
we have it's wrapped around a little bit
let me just zoom that out just a
fraction
so the page number one took 1.25
milliseconds page 26.28 page 50.
surprisingly less time
okay fair enough
um and we can see that page 20 somehow
managed to trigger some Gen 2
collections used three and a half Meg of
memory page 50 3.5 page one 800k
okay cool I'm not going to dig into the
code I don't need to understand why I'm
trying to find performance problems
um one of the Temptations when we're
doing this type of work is to start
digging into more than we should and
losing our focus and then going what the
hell was I doing I've lost track now
um and the disciplined part of problem
solving is really important here
what it tells me is that page 20 is
probably the one we want to focus on in
this particular case so I'm going to go
back to benchmark.net and
just clear that out
and that out and then I'm going to run
this again but I'm now going to profile
the execution for The Benchmark of just
page 20.
so I can do that by doing uh Dash p etw
which is cool this is not going to work
because it's going to say hey you know
what Richard uh you can't do etw tracing
unless you're elevated
and going yes you are correct that's why
I prepared earlier
it's like a cooking show here I think
and here's something I prepared earlier
and I probably want to be in the right
folder thank you for pointing that out
so we'll run that 20 again and this time
it's going to run the profiler alongside
it so we can see exactly what's
happening where CPU is being allocated
within the get page method to try and
find what's occurring
I should probably hit the thing to start
at hey instead of just waiting and going
why is it not running yet
all right so it's doing a build you can
see also in terms of the build that we
are doing the release mode builds we're
turning off building parallel
deterministic optimized true making sure
everything's
all good again these are controllable
settings in benchmark.net
and there we go here's our pilot coming
through 128 operations per batch which
is good or per workload I should say
warm the workload up make sure it's all
good
and then do the actual run
this will run until
benchmark.net decides there's enough
statistical
consistency and then we'll stop
if it doesn't find any consistency it
will run up to 100 times and then go
okay you've had enough we should stop
anyway
it's kind of like when the kids keep
asking can I stay up just a little
longer and you go all right all right no
now let's go to bed
so we're done which is great and we have
generated a profile in this folder here
which I am now going to go and open in
perfume so if I go up to here and change
the folder path to the one we just saw
I've got my Benchmark there I'm going to
open that up double click it
cool now at this point I can jump into
the CPU stacks
I don't want to do that
you're like why why because
stuff's been happening benchmark.net ran
it how many times
I didn't count actually it ran it a few
times but when it runs each
Benchmark each workload it creates an
event
an etw event that we can use to see
what's going on so Benchmark start and
stop is for the entire run
workload actual start and stop are the
things we're interested in this is after
the jit has done its thing after it's
done the piloting after it's done
everything else
and we can then look at two events start
and stop and grab the time
right click that and go hey open the CPU
stacks for just this period of time now
I've narrowed in my investigation to
just a single Benchmark run so I have a
much better view of what's going on
inside the code
and I see here now a few interesting
things I see yes get page sucking up all
my time damn you get page
um decimal calculations some core CLR
stuff that's occurring whatever else
um
but this is a summarized view there's a
grouping that's occurred here
I want to make this less Groot and sorry
about that let's go to no grouping
this is the detail of everything that's
occurring this is
instead of going with summarized things
and trying to help me focus on just the
big picture I'm going into the Weeds now
what is occurring transformation matrix
multiplied decimals transform Etc
there's some oh there's one of those
classic I don't know what the hell this
is
um there is also a little view in perf
view called The Flame graph now this is
fantastic and look at how horrible that
is all at the same time
let me Zoom that out and try using this
on anything and trying to figure out
what's going on I don't want to do that
that's that's not good so I'm going to
take this and save the view as
a speed scope file
speed scope is a nice little utility
that exists online that says hey you can
go and upload performance charts to me
and give you a much more flexible
visualized view of what's going on and I
can dig through things and I can
highlight time and narrow in on ranges
and everything
um
but if you have a look up the left here
there is a left heavy view which is
going to collapse all the calls that are
in the same level of the call stack
shoveling to the left and then try and
group The Children underneath that which
lets me get a better view of overall
time so if I come down I see here
there's some work around
this is transformation matrix transform
and it's taking a PDF Point overall this
is 29 of our execution
hopefully you can see that okay I can
zoom it in one more time just to make it
in bigger
and we also have other methods that are
floating around as well
what's also nice is if I just uh
select all the time again
at a certain level when you click
something you can see hopefully you can
see it will highlight where else that
same method is being called
so I can get a few I feel for where it
is in the call stack and if we're being
recursive and and the like so that's
cool but what I see in general is that
this is all in transformation matrix
multiply there's a lot of work going on
there so
we do what we do which is at this point
go okay and now we're talking let's go
to transformation matrix and let's go to
the multiply method
all right
and here's our method
that's
cool so we're spending 45 of our time in
here
can I improve this code
doesn't look like it right
welcome to Performance work
think beyond the abstraction
what we're doing here and when you
understand how PDFs work a little bit
more is it PDFs are basically to pass
them we have coordinate systems and
we're trying to figure out where things
are on page
PDFs are rendered as effectively
pictures
just
it's how they work and to work out where
a word is and to do a word count you
have to kind of go hey there's letters
and all these letters are near each
other and they all fit within a bounding
box
and to work out the bounding box you
need a coordinate system
and to be accurate the developers built
this with decimals so that we can be
really accurate around where our box is
anyone know what gaming engines use all
the time
they use decimals right
no because decimals suck decimals are
great for finance we want accuracy in
our currency not really useful when
you're doing geometry or not as good
because what's the difference between
this shape and this shape
which is the difference between a
decimal and a float
nothing at all in fact
let's go and prove this not that one
Richard this one
and I mentioned before we were going to
look at the net source code so let's go
to source
.net
and look at the implementation beyond
the abstraction of a decimal
all right here we go
here's your decimal
and let's go look at
operator asterisks which as we know is
our multiplication the multiplication
that's that's really awesome
um there you go operator asterisks
cause another method to do variable
decimal multiplication excellent anyone
know what that does under the hood
no because you've never looked at
neither did I before this
um
here it is we are on line 1323
this will do your heading I'll just
scroll slowly I'll tell you when we hit
the bottom
we're not there yet are we there yet
are we there yet oh look at that comment
90 60 192 bit results what the f okay
where are we still going by the way
and we're still going and oh there we
are no wait no we're not oh damn it oh
look there's go-to's love it
um and then finally we head down to 15
18 and that's the end of our
multiplication method
shall we have a look at double for a
comparison
all right
um I'll just I'll start scrolling I'll
tell you when we stop
all right we stopped
what are we doing with doubles when we
multiply we're effectively putting two
operands into registers and asking the
CPU to multiply them and job done end of
story
because CPUs love floating Point numbers
they will deal with them all day long
decimals are an abstraction over the top
of vintages
painful extra compute time so we want to
improve our performance do we need the
accuracy of a decimal this is where
tests are important
I've got a test Suite I can make some
changes and verify the test still works
so let's make that change
and when I say make that change let's
actually jump to the branch
and what I'm going to do here is go to
step three
in the code I've now built
in my benchmarks a new Benchmark using
PDF point this is a one of those smaller
classes
um that if we have a look at it is
effectively an x and y coordinate as a
decimal and an X of y coordinate as a
double I create a new version of that so
I can compare the decimal implementation
with the double implementation and do
some operations on it to see how it runs
this is fun I like doing this it's great
um
so now we're going to run our benchmark
and I'm going to run our PDF point one
number one this time
just to compare two different
implementations of exactly the same code
changing just the types
anyone want to have a guess of how much
faster this will be
given you saw the 300 lines or whatever
it was in code
it's going to be at least one percent
right
all right so I think this is the decimal
one running first I can't tell you but
you can see how many operations are in
each workload
6.7 67 million is that the number 67
million that's cool
that's a good number
all right do your thing do your thing do
your thing I'll just sing to myself
do you want me to tell some jokes while
this is running
I was gonna say tell some bad dad jokes
but there are no bad dad jokes just so
you know
and how many operations for this one
five one two three five hundred and
thirty six million operations I'm
guessing this one's going to be a little
bit faster
all right
come on baby you can do it
how many work light actuals before we
stop 18.
do I hear 20.
are you 25
this is always part of the fun right
when will this finish four hours later
come on
38.
all right
look at the difference
because we went beyond the abstraction
we focused on an area we went through
the loop we measured we Baseline we
changed
to verify things now this is a very
discreet piece of work that we're doing
here this is not necessarily something
that will work across the entire
application but I can see that by simply
for this method moving from decimals to
doubles for this point improved
performance by
I can't even do that as a percentage
it's now 0.6 of a percent of the time it
took before
now that's
freaking awesome
um let's go one step further and apply
it across the entire code base shall we
where relevant now it should only be for
geometries
there are certain other numbers that
make sense as decimals and if we change
them to floats are going to cause bugs
um probably don't want to do that so we
do need to be careful which is again why
it's important to have that test Suite
there
so let's get switched to step four
and in this case
I've now gone and behind the scenes
you'll see that I've added things for
the transformation matrix I had a
decimal and a double implementation and
I changed things around and I've moved
it all about and everything else which
I'm not going to run through with you
what I am going to do
is go back to our low ball quality
performance tester application
just to go finger in the air the entire
operation roughly how much has it
improved
guesses
no guesses
if only that were true
all right let's run release mode
now you can tell that I've made changes
because I haven't cleaned up the
compiler warnings
welcome to Richard's development
technique 101
if you can't see that
maybe you can see that
in fact let's do it without the Run bin
release net six
uh performance test uh dot XE
so we had 4.4
4.1
four point hopefully four
two
so roughly what now
four two four three something like that
four two are we okay with that number
pretend that I've run this 98 times and
I've run the Jet and I've done all the
other stuff that benchmark.net does
beautifully
um
all right so uh let's go to our notepad
where we had our rough numbers before
and we are now at 4.3 seconds so from
our starting point of dot net core 31
which was a cheating start point I get
it
um I'm going to say I'm claiming it
anyway that we got almost a 50 well 40
Improvement something like that we've
saved 3.5 seconds
not bad for one hour's work wasn't one
hour's work just pretend
um but even from our.net6 code we have
saved over two seconds so there's a 30
Improvement for the same run time simply
because we went through that process of
having the tests Thinking Beyond the
surface level
Baseline change Baseline again now when
I Was preparing this talk I did do the
good thing of making performance worse
through some of the changes I was trying
again this is why the baselining is
there because you want to know that when
you've made the change it has made a
difference a positive difference
so coming back to our slides
so detective work with puzzle solving we
went we identified we baselined
we came we saw we conquered it was
fantastic
then we went home and watched Netflix
um
the tools we used perfview
benchmark.net
speed scope to visualize that flame
graph in a better way that's not
something you have to do but these are
all free tools which is great
and going beyond the surface at times
for the.net source code now you might in
some of your applications not be going
to dot net source code but going into
third-party libraries
with most of our things being on nuget a
lot of our dependencies on nuget and
open source these days being able to dig
into third-party libraries is a normal
part of development you should and I
would encourage you to do that
with the Microsoft source code
it's all open as well
yeah.net codes out there in invisible in
the public you might not want to dive
into that given what we saw
leave that for others and just
understand the framework's good but at
times you might want to go and have a
look and see what it's doing under the
hood
um and again
investigate Beyond just what your code
does it's really easy to look online at
a line of code and go this looks pretty
simple and move on I did that with what
we looked at
today the first time I went through it
okay there's some Matrix numbers okay
fine move on and it wasn't until I
stepped back paused and went
hang on
why are we using decimals
where's the value and I went ah
beyond the surface level
all right and at that point
we are done I even finished early
because it's a performance talk
bad jokes aside
um
that's it in terms of talk we're done
now go back to work or go enjoy the rest
of the conference or ask questions I'm
open for questions
yo
experience
okay so the question what's the
experience like upskilling Junior
developers with this pair programming
more than anything else I mentioned
before the overthreading problem that
was someone who had less experience in
the industry and the way I helped them
through that was to walk through and
literally do something like this as a an
example of the process and just show
them by example step by step it does
take time but you know it's the classic
teach someone to fish versus do the
fishing for them and so they can then
take that and apply it themselves
afterwards so just look for those
opportunities and see how it goes from
there
good question other ones
up the back and behind the spotlight
that I can't see
is perfume for Mac
perfume is available for Linux at least
the Gathering of data actually I'll show
you
here we'll just go to uh
github.com
Microsoft perfview
and it's dot net core so you can jump in
and get perf View and Trace events which
are all built in
um that's downloadable and and run it um
previous versions.net purview 2 Trace
event was separate so if you're running
in Linux you had to go and run trace
event to do the capture separately and
bring it back to Windows to analyze I'm
pretty sure three is now runnable on
um on Mac and Linux and everything else
because it's a net core program and
uses WPF Maybe
I haven't looked at that part of the
source code
um
but yeah should be okay
other questions uh over here
yep
and it's not obviously how to make it
feel less yeah
that's the how do you go beyond the
surface level question so the question
just to repeat is if I find something
that I think needs to be improved but
I'm not sure how to improve it what do I
do
um
what do most people do in that situation
you start exploring you start trying
things and this is where that baselining
and and re-measuring becomes really
important so it might take you a few
iterations to play around with it and go
I don't know you know for example I'm
doing string manipulation do I want to
turn this from a string into a span and
then do some work across spans for
example or use a memory of type T kind
of construct
um
only one way to find out
try it see if it works or not the other
thing you can do is look up the tree so
it's not always what's below it's what
what you're being called from
and maybe you're being called too many
times from parent code so again
something like the flame graph
you might see that there are lots of
callers coming into the same method and
that your method is spread everywhere so
maybe it's a case of
collating that and doing a work in batch
somewhere else or pre-computing things
and and changing some of your
application design
so that you're not as chatty
particularly for Network calls and the
like
um
there's no real
guidance I can give you other than to
try stuff but think more about the
problem overall not just the specific so
you will go deep and you will also go up
in terms of nice work
other questions
yep
um so yes though there's some of the
tools you'll use microservices are going
to be you're looking at the network
calls so in the profiler yep
um sorry yeah
waiting for
it to work
probably
for a single service so the question
just for those who didn't hear is what
do we do in a micro Services situation
um so if we're doing a single service
it's effectively an executable so you
know you you might want to abstract away
uh Network because I have mock
implementations
if you are running in kubernetes there's
a tool we use internally called
telepresence where we can actually have
our app or our microservice is deployed
to a cluster and using telepresence run
one service locally and basically proxy
Network traffic to my local machine and
back up so I can run a full environment
with just one service on my local
machine and do work around that so that
if that's a value
uh Telly Telly presence dot IO this uh
cool thing here that's
yep well they changed the website
um
that's effectively this I'll just quiet
we're going way off track here but
that's okay I don't mind doing that
um
this one
one of these architecture something
uh
load the page no that's intercepts
anyway
um
effectively this tool will as I said do
proxy until from your local machine so
you can then attach to your local
machine you don't even have to run it in
a container
you can actually run a local process and
have the traffic intercepted going to
and from which is just
fantastic
needs a bit of setup you've got to have
some obviously uh updates on the cluster
to put in the the Interceptor don't do
it in production
but that could work alternatively you
try and run containers or mock services
or something so you can isolate but yeah
uh final question from anyone
I can't see if you're over there but
that's okay all right well in that case
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
go enjoy NDC and I will talk to you soon
foreign
[Applause]